THAT’S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
ANGLE.
IF A TREE FALLS IN A FOREST AND
NO ONE IS AROUND TO HEAR IT,
DOESN’T MAKE A SOUND?
THAT IS THE AGE-OLD
PHILOSOPHICAL THOUGHT EXPERIMENT
ABOUT PERCEPTION AND
OBSERVATION.
BUT AFTER THIS WEEKEND WE CAN
MODIFY IT THIS WAY.
IF A TRUMP MARCH DRAWS TENS OF
THOUSANDS, MAYBE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE, PATRIOTIC
PEOPLE TO WASHINGTON AND NO ONE
IS AROUND TO REPORT IT, DID IT
REALLY OCCUR?
IT WAS BILLED AS THE MILLION
MAGA MARCH.
TENS OF THOUSANDS.
LOOK AT THE OVERHEAD SHOT, IT
COULD BE ONE OF THE BIGGEST
GRASSROOTS PROTEST OF CAPITAL
HAS EVER SEEN.
ATTENDEES WERE FAMILY, YOUNG,
OLD, BLACK, WHITE, HISPANIC.
THEY CAME FROM NEAR AND FAR ALL
TO SUPPORT THE AMERICA FIRST
AGENDA AND TO STAND WITH A MAN
WHO WAS ENDURED SO MUCH IN ORDER
TO LEAD THE MOVEMENT.
>> WE NEED TRUMP FOREVER.
>> [INDISTINCT]
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE KNOW IT.
YOU CAN SEE.
>> FOUR MORE YEARS.
>> Laura: IT’S A FAIR GUESS
THAT MOST OF THAT GIGANTIC CROWD
ARE CONVINCED THAT TRUMP WON THE
ELECTION.
IT IS LIKEWISE REASONABLE FOR
THEM TO CONCLUDE THAT THEY DON’T
HAVE MUCH TRUST IN THE U.S.
MEDIA.
POCKETS OR EVEN CHANTING AGAINST
THIS NEWS CHANNEL FOR WHAT THEY
PERCEIVE AS ELECTION NIGHT BIAS
AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
OTHERS WERE RIGHTFULLY OUTRAGED
THAT FEW NETWORKS WERE EVEN
CARRYING THE RALLY AT ALL.
THE ONES WHO DID WERE ONLY
INTERESTED IN ASSAULTING THE
ATTENDEES.
>> THE PRESIDENT’S SUPPORTERS
POURED INTO THE STREETS OF
WASHINGTON TO TRY TO GIVE LOVE
TOLIFE TO THESE UNFOUNDED CLAIMS
HOW DID HE BECOME NORMAL?
>> GOOD LUCK GETTING A CLEAR OR
FACT-BASED LOGICAL ANSWER TO
SOME OF THE QUESTIONS.
>> THESE PEOPLE ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY A JOKE.
THESE AREN’T SERIOUS PEOPLE.
THESE ARE MEMBERS OF A CULT.
I HOPE THEY GET FROSTBITE.
>> Laura: I HOPE THEY GET
FROSTBITE IS WHAT HE SAID.
REMEMBER, THESE TALKING HEADS
ARE SOME OF THE KIND, TOLERANT,
UNIFYING AND LOVING PEOPLE THAT
BIDEN AND HARRIS CLAIM MAKE UP
THEIR MOVEMENT.
73 MILLION PEOPLE VOTED FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND IT’S NOT TOO
MUCH FOR THEM TO EXPECT, IS IT?
THAT THE MEDIA TREAT THEM FAIRLY
AND RESPECTFULLY.
LIKEWISE IT’S NOT TOO MUCH FOR
THEM TO EXPECT THAT ONLY LEGAL
VOTES WILL BE COUNTED AND THAT
THEIR VOTES MUST NOT BE
NULLIFIED DUE TO FRAUD.
FOR YEARS NOW, I HAVE BEEN
SPEAKING ABOUT THIS TYPE OF
HONEST, HARDWORKING AMERICAN WHO
CAME TO WASHINGTON OVER THE
WEEKEND.
THROUGHOUT THIS TIME THE
SO-CALLED ELITES AND OUR
NATION’S CAPITAL HAVE RESPONDED
TO THE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS WITH MOCKERY
AND CONTEMPT.
IT’S DUMBFOUNDING TO ME THAT THE
MEDIA AND DEMOCRATS STILL DON’T
UNDERSTAND WHAT A STUPID
STRATEGY IS TO ALIENATE AND
DISMISS ALL OF THESE AMERICANS.
I THINK THEY’RE MAKING THE SAME
MISTAKE THEY MADE IN 2009 AND IN
2010 WHEN THE MUCH SMALLER TEA
PARTY MOVEMENT STARTED.
>> SEEING THE TEA PARTY MOVEMENT
AS A REAL POLITICAL FORCE THIS
YEAR?
>> IT SEEMS TO BE A VERY
SUCCESSFUL PRIVATE ENTERPRISE.
>> NOBODY KNOWS WHAT THEY ARE
FOR.
WE KNOW WHAT THEY ARE AGAINST.
>> IT’S NOT ABOUT TAXES.
IT’S ABOUT HATING A BLACK MAN IN
THE WHITE HOUSE.
WE CALL IT ASTROTURF.
IT’S REALLY NOT A GRASSROOTS
MOVEMENT.
>> YOU WATCH A CERTAIN NEWS
CHANNEL ON WHICH I AM NOT VERY
POPULAR.
YOU SEE FOLKS WAVING TEA BAGS
AROUND.
>> Laura: THEY THOUGHT THAT
ALL THAT CONDESCENSION WOULD
MAKE THE MOVEMENT GO AWAY.
IT ONLY MADE THE TEA PARTY
STRONGER.
LESS THAN TWO YEARS AFTER THOSE
INSULT REPUBLICANS TOOK CONTROL
OF THE HOUSE IN 2010.
SOME OF THE TEA PARTY CANDIDATES
INCLUDE THOSE LITTLE-KNOWN
PEOPLE.
KRISTI NOEM, MARCO RUBIO,
TED CRUZ, RAND PAUL, TIM SCOTT
AND MIKE LEE.
FOUR YEARS LATER, THE G.O.P.
TOOK CONTROL OF THE SENATE.
TWO YEARS AFTER THAT,
DONALD TRUMP WAS ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE TEA
PARTY THEN AND PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
MOVEMENT NOW IS THAT THIS
MOVEMENT NOW HAS A LOT MORE
CLARITY ABOUT WHAT IT WANTS.
THE SAME TRUMP ECONOMIC AND
FOREIGN POLICY AGENDA THAT LED
TO HIGHER WAGES, FEWER WARS.
WHATEVER THE FINAL ACTUAL
COLLEGE ITALIANS, THIS MOVEMENT
HAS PROVEN TRACK RECORD OF
SUCCESS ON EVERYTHING FROM
ACHIEVING OUR ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE TO CHALLENGING
CHINA TO FAST TRACKING A COVID
VACCINE, RAISING FAMILY INCOMES.
THE RESULTS WERE SO IMPRESSIVE
THAT NOT ONLY DID
PRESIDENT TRUMP BROADEN HIS
COALITION AMONG WORKING-CLASS
AMERICANS BUT HE HELPED GROW THE
PARTIES NUMBERS IN THE HOUSE.
WHEN ALL THOSE VAUNTED MEDIA
EXPERTS WITH ALL THEIR
CREDENTIALS WERE PREDICTING THE
OPPOSITE.
THEY CLAIMED TRUMP WAS GOING TO
SHRINK THE PARTY.
REMEMBER THAT?
ESPECIALLY ON MINORITIES.
WRONG AGAIN.
>> BLACKS AND LATINOS ARE DOING
MUCH BETTER UNDER TRUMP VERSUS
OBAMA.
ABSOLUTELY.
>> OPPORTUNITY ZONES.
SOMETHING THAT MY OPINION OF
SEES [INDISTINCT]
>> WE’VE DONE A LOT OF THINGS.
BUSINESS HAVE COME TO MIND
NEIGHBORHOOD.
BLACK PEOPLE OWN HOMES.
>> Laura: WHY COULDN’T THE
NETWORKS FIND THESE PEOPLE TO
INTERVIEW?
THEY WERE THERE.
WE FOUND THEM.
IN A BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THAT
THAT YOU JUST SAW, ALL THOSE
GAINS, THEY ARE GOING TO BE
FLUSHED DOWN THE TOILET.
HIS HANDLERS WERE BASICALLY ALL
ALL OBAMA STAFFERS BELIEVE IN
SOMETHING CALLED THE GREAT RESET
OF CAPITALISM.
I TOLD YOU ABOUT THIS LAST WEEK.
IT’S A PLAN TO FORCE A MORE
EQUITABLE DISTRIBUTION OF GLOBAL
RESOURCES.
TRANSLATION: MOST AMERICANS WILL
HAVE LESS FREEDOM AND LESS MONEY
EXCEPT FOR THE SAME ELITES WHO
ALWAYS FIND A WAY AROUND THE
RULES.
LIKE DURING THE LOCKDOWNS WHEN
THE FAMILIES OF THESE MANY
TYRANTS SKIRTED THE RESTRICTIONS
RESTRICTIONS.
JUST LAST WEEK CALIFORNIA
GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM WAS DINING
WITH A PROHIBITED NUMBER OF
PILES AT THE EXPENSE OF LONGER,
THE FRENCH LAUNDRY.
CHICAGO MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT WAS
CAUGHT PARTING MASK WAS IN A
MASSIVE CROWD CELEBRATING
BIDEN’S UNOFFICIAL ELECTION WIN.
NO PROBLEM.
PELOSI WAS GOING TO HAVE A BIG
CONGRESSIONAL SOIREE UNTIL SHE
WAS SHAMED INTO CANCELING IT.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE ONTO
THESE FRAUDS.
THE SPEED 23 MERGERS COULDN’T
HAVE BEEN CLEARER ABOUT WHAT
COVID LOCKDOWNS AND RESTRICTIONS
HAVE DONE TO AMERICA.
>> WHAT TRUMP SAID IN THE
BEGINNING.
THE CURE CAN’T BE WORSE THAN THE
DISEASE ITSELF.
WE STILL NEED TO GO ON.
>> TRY TO FINISH OFF ANY
BUSINESS.
HANGING ON BY THE SKIN OF THEIR
TEETH.
>> NANCY PELOSI, JOE BIDEN, THEY
TALK ABOUT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
BUT YOU SHUT THE COUNTRY DOWN
FOR FOUR TO SIX WEEKS IT WILL BE
THE FINAL NAIL IN THE COFFIN.
>> Laura: 100% TRUE.
BUT SO FAR JOE BIDEN AND HIS
HANDLERS AREN’T LISTENING.
BIDEN LOVES TO TALK ABOUT
DIGNITY AND UNITY AND RESPECT.
BUT THE TIME FOR TALK IS OVER AT
THE TIME FOR ACTION IS HERE.
BECAUSE OF BIDEN REALLY WANTED
TO UNITE THE COUNTRY, HE
WOULDN’T EVEN BE ENTERTAINING
THE IDEA OF DESTROYING OUR
CURRENT ECONOMIC RECOVERY WITH
ANOTHER DEVASTATING LOCKDOWN OR
SERIES OF LOCKDOWNS.
IF BIDEN REALLY WANTED TO UNITE
THE COUNTRY, HE WOULD NOT
DISMISS THE CONCERNS OF TENS OF
MILLIONS OF AMERICANS ABOUT
MAIL-IN VOTING.
INSTEAD HE WOULD DO SOMETHING
LIKE, I DON’T KNOW, POINT OF
BIPARTISAN COMMISSION TO ANSWER
EVERY QUESTION ABOUT HOW THIS
ELECTION WAS CONDUCTED AND TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT WE WILL NEVER
HAVE TO WAIT SO LONG FOR AN
ACCURATE COUNT.
IF JOE BIDEN REALLY WANTED TO
UNITE THE COUNTRY, HE WOULD HAVE
PERSONALLY AND ON CAMERA
CONDEMNED THE BLM AND ANTIFA
THUGS WHO BEAT, KICKED, AND
HARASSED TRUMP SUPPORTERS ON
SATURDAY.
HE HAS DONE NONE OF THESE
THINGS.
HE STILL HOPES THIS MOVEMENT IS
JUST GOING TO GO AWAY.
THAT’S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
HERE ARE SOME HARD TRUTHS FOR
JOE BIDEN, HIS HANDLERS AND
ENABLERS IN THE PRESS CORPS.
YOU KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
THE PRO-TRUMP SARONGS DIDN’T
SHOW UP IN D.C. ON SATURDAY
BECAUSE OF CONSERVATIVE MEDIA
BECAUSE WE TOLD THEM TO.
THEY SHOWED UP KNOWING THEY
COULD BE PHYSICALLY ATTACKED FOR
DOING SO BECAUSE THEY LOVE
AMERICA.
LYING ABOUT THEM, INSULTING
THEM, IGNORING THEM WILL ONLY
INCITE MORE VIOLENCE AND MORE
RESENTMENT AND OPPOSITION.
ALL AMERICANS DESERVE TO BE
HEARD, TO BE SEEN, AND TO BE